with some information try to fill in a
few things that might not be immediately
obvious on our website but you can
always turn your website and and and
follow up and find even more specific
things about when your application is
due and details about the GRE Shannon
are trading systems pointed out to me
that there is one typo on your handout
that is really very important and that
is that you must take the GRE by
December 15 in order for us to get
scores by December 31st so that your
application can be complete so that's
very very important and if you haven't
if you're planning to apply and go to
Jerry's please please go ahead and do
that you know go to Jerry exciting
pulling your zip code and play around a
little bit I just put in the zip code
for Cambridge yesterday just to see the
nearest testing facility with
availability and December 15th was in
Connecticut oh boy if everyone's on top
of this but I will I will add not to
totally panic you that this is probably
the area in the country where the most
people in the US
take the Jerry's because it's a brain
trust as he lives in Boston so many
universities so a lot of panic people
are the way the to go ahead and schedule
that test if you've not done so already
I am Heather and you're shot I am the
director of Graduate Studies for
comparative media space hello this is
Kurt prevent full of Pokkiri to sit
there and pull up a chair we have people
coming in and out a lot
[Music]
in between to come by say hi use
themselves jing wang' there's one of our
professors who later we've got a manager
we've got three students so we've got a
mix of people that will change
throughout the next two hours I
mentioned Shannon already our
administrative assistant who loses
source of all knowledge anything you
can't figure out by asking you're
looking for whatever it's Shannon can
tell you so I'm going to initially do
something that I tell people never to do
in PowerPoint presentations which is to
say some of the things that are written
right out behind me so bear with me imma
give you the brief overview of what
comparative Media Studies is we like to
think that we address the challenges
brought about my ongoing and fundamental
changes in the technologies and
practices of media production
distribution and consumption and rather
than looking at median specific silos
we're trying to look at that nagisa
media change in a comparative historical
and multidisciplinary where across
mediums so if you've been looking at
other kinds of graduate programs over
the country you may have seen course of
programs in film studies or film and
Media Studies or screen studies which if
people thought was a really great
solution of the coming of new media a
few years ago they're like well you used
to just look at TV but now we film and
computer screens and can tell the
screens and this will sort of cover
everything it's not a bad idea
except for audio radio different kinds
of interfaces that aren't that are about
media but aren't screened specific so
with comparative Media Studies we try to
come up with a rubric that was more
inclusive more multidisciplinary or
transdisciplinary some people are a
little confused and they go to the
website and they're like
what is this w what's going on um so I
just explained that CMS W is a composite
program in a merger and I leave it's
2012 between comparative Media Studies
and writing humanistic studies and so
what we have is two graduate programs
and two undergraduate programs right the
graduate program on the W side is a
science writing program and then we have
the comparative Media Center side and
those and both of those graduate
programs are Masters of Science degrees
and then the undergrad degrees are you
know separate things and as a graduate
student you wouldn't necessarily
interact with the undergrads but it's
neat to know that we have a pretty
strong undergraduate program we have
among highest numbers of majors and
humanities at MIT people don't tend to
come into my t to study literature or
sociology or you know they come here to
to learn engineering but the undergrads
are required to take a humanities
classes while they're here to a year
which meet which is very which is a lot
for a technically oriented school and
they come to see the value of humanities
and they technically oriented yeah
academic environment and this makes us a
really good place to be because we
consider ourselves as they're doing
applied humanities that we are
humanities that make sense in the
context of a technologically oriented
Institute so we're based in shafts
School of Humanities Arts and Social
Sciences MIT overall was recently ranked
one of the three best universities after
Harvard and Stanford in the world for
arts and humanities education by x
higher education which is a leading
British education magazine event and
then we were ranked number one in the
social sciences so we're doing pretty
well outside of just the things you
would think of immediately like
engineering and
rocket design and space travel and so on
the comparative events program has
graduated over a hundred students at
this point and here do you know the
exact number 150 or 160 okay and another
source of information
remember communications director I would
say about 30% of those masters students
pursue doctoral degrees we try to take
about ten a year depends upon funding
because we really like to fund every one
that we bring in we want to cover your
tuition we want to provide you a
research assistantship that will cover
your cost of living expenses and so on
and we're very committed to making that
happen so if we keep if we have ten we
we can only fund eight or nine then that
is what we bring in that's the right
thing to do so if we have a class of ten
typically about three people would
pursue a PhD program from us and the
other 70% will go into variety of
professional endeavors such as game
design TV production management museum
education and not-for-profit work
advertising marketing really a wide
range of areas and if hopefully you're
all aware that we have an alumni session
tonight from 5:00 to 6:30 Shannon what's
that room for there's actually a little
easier to find than this one and we want
for CMS along there too who are graduate
while ago one from relief oh four and
maybe every 105 or oh six around there
and to who who graduate just a few years
ago so and this is part of our
colloquium series I'll talk about more
about colloquium later but it would give
you a chance to get a sense of what CMS
they'll love do what they're up to and
also ask them questions and that kind of
thing
we currently receive about 100
applications a year and as I said we
admit somewhere
and in 10 I told you it's a fully funded
programming to the best of our ability
mostly if you give these research lab
sponsorships and the program I'll walk
you through the course requirements and
so on but basically you take a range of
courses for your first year and a half
when you're spending your last semester
although it is starting before that and
your preliminary research and so on but
you spend the end of the program you
your culminating the program with the
creation of a master's thesis which is a
written work of 70 to 100 or so pages
sometimes it has a strong digital
component and online component we've had
a student for example who has written a
thesis but also produced a documentary
to go along with that thesis or at least
a rock-cut so sometimes these projects
get very ambitious I have people come to
my office and say well I want to write a
thesis but also do a website and look
with that but let's focus on the thesis
to start with fell on that you have to
be careful not to bite off more than you
can chew and students will get
experience not through the program not
only doing this kind of individual work
which is what a thesis is but also
through various kinds of teamwork
whether that means working together in
your lab we're working on publications
together giving group presentations and
some of the things that are three
representative students could probably
talk about a little bit in more detail
in a few minutes um yeah so here are the
four big [ __ ] elements of Murphy is
Zoey's we are transmedia we are trying
to distort oh we're trying its cultural
and we are trans
disciplinary here are photos of which
I'm not sure about you can see but of
all of our faculty so we've got of the
McFaul team works on documentary
production and also have this very
interesting platform that he's developed
for Indian immigrant communities to
share their histories it's basically a
kind of place where people find
photographs of their families can put
them up and that people could say
aligning that guy you know I work with
him in Brooklyn in 1952 and so he's
building history in this kind of very
managed crowdsource kind of way among
his own subjects that he's history
Frederico felonio is a professor of the
practice who runs the mobile experience
lab which I am told is soon to be
rebranded as design lab okay
in Condry is an anthropologist who works
on anime and in Japan and on pop music
Japanese pop music and the economics of
the global music industry fashion
consumption chalk works on civic media
issues he's written a book on transmedia
activism and immigrant communities in
the Los Angeles area or some a number of
social justice issues boxer L runs the
imagination computation and expression
laboratory and so he's in receiving
cognition issues an experimental
computational production that is
organized around him intersectionality
and identity issues Heather give you
shot but me I work on conservative and
right-wing media culture my most recent
book was on believing that Buckley who
tried to get all the crazy weird people
out of the conservative movement and
forge a more legitimate
image for that
come back Eric Klopfer works on stem and
educational games and runs the yes
Nick Mumford does a computational poetry
really really interesting stuff and just
a perfect example of this sort of merger
of human and humanities makers and
Technology interested in me because he's
often working on ways that computers
themselves in generating poetry but he
used not just computers he's bringing
two he's been for example he's been
working for a long time on a book of a
book that would be composed of nothing
but three letter words Lisa parks works
on international issues around on
technology and surveillance and military
technology she's got a new book out
called life in the age of drones which
she's been working on a very interesting
cell phone apps for use in Turkey and
other countries where there's quite a
bit of censorship and help me people to
use their cell phones when they're
worried about surveillance but they want
to talk about things that aren't illegal
like birth control issues or game was
the rights issues and so on she's up
there working in a team to develop that
with health center kind of situation Jim
parity works on surveillance and history
science as Shelby is our head who will
be stopping by later after meeting
depends on wealthy unclear he's got a
big administrative me so he will stop by
but he is a rhetorician who also works
on contemporary media issues he's got so
it's done quite a bit worth of Michael
Moore's films and also work on
transgender identity in the media
Justin Reich runs the Geller teacher
education program and now again wait but
he does work with Steph right yeah okay
and the teaching since next left-tailed
Taylor versus sociologists who focuses
on eSports William or Ricky oh so many
things yeah historical working degree
work and there is a futuristic work he
wants the mentoring let up and is
particularly for his research on virtual
reality and finally Jane Wayne who works
on who has a NGO called NGO NGO 2.0 in
China and works on media and advertising
in China she can fill you in what she
does in just a moment after all these
slides so they give you a sense of our
range and interdisciplinarity of it I
mean we have people who trained in very
conventional humanities fields I myself
was an undergraduate double major in
French and film studies and I went to
grad school to study feminist film
theory and then I became self-taught as
TV study scholar and
radio and you know so we come from an
interesting range of backgrounds and
I've mentioned we have these research
groups that help us sort of put our
theory or critical ideas into practice
that also provide for my funding
opportunities for our students so the
the center Pacific media the education
arcade game lab the mobile experience
play of the imagination computation
expression lab hyper studio global media
technology two cultures laughs that's of
course a new lab that's our newest one I
believe teaching systems lab also new
ish older documentary lab that I just
mentioned and the Trotec which is new
mouth words and rap writing rhetoric and
professional okay and I'll just mention
that if you are here and you are funded
through a research lab that would entail
about 20 hours will be of of work we do
our best to learn your interest with
your lab I already mentioned who directs
what labs so I won't belabor this too
much but some of them have a professor
who is doing the lead as research
director and some of them have research
directors like oh my god laughs answer
all of them and so on so you can look at
all that our website another part of our
program is that we have visiting
scholars and postdocs so for example
China I see Coates was here for two
years as the Martin Luther King visiting
scholar teaching kind of more on the W
side about memoir long-form rating
memoir Theresa Rojas who worked on
comics and
no identity Korean mentally pho who's an
open da clap artists artists filmmakers
residents so we we usually have about
ten visitors and residents ranging from
a semester to a year or two that no
postdocs are often here for two years
and it adds a kind of fresh blood kind
of constantly coming into the program
and some of these people also teach
courses and they're also just here as a
resource you know we don't jump era D
for example teaches a comics class but
comics has been slower to develop as
part of our curriculum but since we had
Teresa robots if your interest in comics
you could search her at the top issues
so the visiting scholars help sort of
bring like this and new stuff to what
we're doing
um this is these materials all along the
website again so I'll try to actually
see this yes okay um so run through the
curriculum for you in the first year you
take media theories and methods one
follow I immediately recent methods to
in the spring so in the first course
you're surveying a broad range of recent
methods in Media Studies culminating
typically with an annotated bibliography
that relates to your thesis idea and we
really are looking for very directed
people who come here with an idea about
what they want their thesis to be on
although it shouldn't necessarily just
sort of be solidified and concrete if
you think you will you want to be
flexible and opening up you're taking
classes that sort of open your mind to
different possibilities but because it
is such a fast-paced program someone who
had very very squishy general ideas but
my thesis will be on education in the
future no to general so we like a more
sort of specific focus you can really
hit the ground running with your studies
and looking forward to your thesis so
you would end the theories and methods
one with an annotated bibliography
typically that's a final assignment um
and then the reason methods two ends
with a proposal for what your paper then
you got workshop one which varies
depending on who is teaching it but
tends to have a strong hands-on
component we either need a Texas a
textual analysis class start thinking
about the content the media technology
oh and then colloquium is a series I
mentioned earlier that means every
Thursday that is part of your coursework
except all you have to do is register
for it and show up it's great you don't
dry papers you don't prepare ahead of
time you might look up who the speaker
is because you might be really
interesting to you and you want to
network with them but you want to make a
reception afterwards and you want to
talk to them occasionally we are able to
take people out to dinner together after
colloquium so it's a great opportunity
to just sit back in the urn thing and
there's a lot of time for Q&A
during this colloquium stew so it's a
nice opportunity learning stuff but also
just to hang out with your community
basically and then in the second
semester already mentioned the music
theory ximénez - we said workshop - and
it never quite jell the way we wanted we
kept changing what we were doing in that
class we were just turning the bull's
eye and then we decided AHA let's open
it up let's give people more electives
as a possibility and so what we came up
with was a list of managed electives it
all had a kind of hands-on component
some kind of production element to them
whether that meant writing code or
designing something
something and so we came up with a list
of Shannon would you say it doesn't
about it done in the now we can all be
sort of added and subtracted that over
time we actually asked Anika longer to
develop a new class in computation
expression so that students won't have a
place built for graduate students to
learn about computational work and then
you have another so that's a that's an
elective but from a managed listen and
you have another over an elective which
you did here we could also take it
harder the world
Wellesley or maths arts that doesn't
have too much but people do tend to go
to Harvard and sometimes making
something say the School of Education
sometimes people sort of the collective
spirit at Sloan which has a media
element to a very strong business
orientation and once again and then
you're sitting here first semester
meaning transition is a sort of
transmedia historical class in media
studies you've got two electives and
colloquium the second semester your
thesis sometimes people will just audit
a class that would be useful for their
pieces for example but that they don't
want to take other assignments for the
thesis if you've you example this is
impossible to read from from where you
are but maybe those watching the live
stream so just a few examples pieces by
Chris carriage recently a critical
breaking to allow for eclectic and
creative damage announcements of
instances of error breakdown and failure
additional assistance like for example
how gamers to like working system until
it broke down what happened there and
the Canadians wrote a piece is called
the award choice agency and world
building and branchy path
and media universes so that was much
more textual oriented analysis than some
of the more bigger technologically
oriented outlet communality Josh
Powell's from Trump Tower to the White
House in 140 characters remediated
election of a paranoid copies president
then we had my Wagner technologies
technocracy toward design strategies for
critical communication technology and
one last example George to the Arabists
everything is awful snark it's
ritualized social practice in online
discourse so that gives you a nice sense
of the rage the number of our alums have
written books this was a nice example of
someone who actually wrote a book read
on the Beast smaller solder 15 Hooda
greediness people call distributed
denial-of-service actions and the
challenges you know she always like to
include a cheap normal picture of a cat
and her powerpoint presentation and I
another book by one of our graduates I
went through not the nothing back our
associate professor of communication at
University of Michigan right now wrote a
book called from Bombay to Bali with an
Asian media industry we've got Kennedy's
talisman from the classic books you have
climate change comes to matter that you
know like facts I need is a champ remote
to networking peripheries technological
features of digital universalism here's
another one actually kevinturtle
recently came and spoke at our Queen
Maud we need help on lots of o9 the US
just cooperative
right Jacobson right those textbook
students reporting system architecture
technology and the emergence of
cinematic space I'm almost done
we need transient in remote nine gasps
stutter there's a full list of our alum
right on our website so you can get a
sense of what they're doing now what it
does it's graduation so I want I'll just
read a lot this list at the bottom we've
seen careers in radio and pocket radio
podcast strategist we've got a fellow at
San Francisco mayor's office of civic
innovation manager of digital
entertainment in Warhol Museum product
manager for Apple consumer intelligence
program manager at Etsy so that gives
you a sense of the range I already told
you about the weekly colloquium series
bring it home and so that's my very
quick run-through
I wonder I'd like to open up with
questions but I would like to hear from
a couple of people up here too
I wonder if we could start with Jane
because I know she needs to cut out for
a lunch meeting and maybe she could
introduce yourself and talk a little
more about the research yeah come on up
here good soup that you can stand up or
just let me use one sentence to describe
what I do I'm interested in studying the
impact of new media on commercial
communication as in advertising I'm also
interested in
had the social media on civic
communication and said civic communities
on the commercial side of things are
they one of the focuses of my work is on
the changing fortunes of TV digital and
social and I look at them from the
perspectives of branding and advertising
research now lately I've been expanding
my advertising research to the larger
question of the changing media ecosystem
in the US and in China and I'm
particularly drawn to to what I would
call a phenomenon of vertical crossovers
vertical cross overs meaning tech
companies are branching into crossing
over into the media sector competing
with traditional content makers and
traditional content distributors and I
think so one of the burning questions in
that area of research is how do we
understand how do we understand the ways
that digitalization is shaping is
pushing country industry boundaries how
do we understand the world of sectors
without borders so that's the commercial
side of my research on the civic side of
things I am a believer about the
importance of practicing work will be
right about so as Charlie relation
apart from teaching and doing research
rightly I'm also running another
organization in China practicing I see
keep our activism so I never put in both
because what to find all the technology
is enabling the crossover so this is a
very quick of Versailles view of what I
do and professor Heather also asked me
to share it the topics of some of the
thesis that I advise and supervising the
past something to give you a quick
preview see in this writing students
work on okay one of them is a case study
about that policy like tons of future
lab I say the hanukkah is an Austrian
cultural educational and 70 foot
Institute they are active in the area in
the field of new media our other thesis
the sixth generation of filmmakers in
China and their relationships and
another thesis on emphasizing electric
science in Manhattan New York between
1881 and 1970 another one a remake of
Chinese animation and then online PBS
sphere PBS refers to the tradition
remains an important system and then a
thesis some hidden activism media
practices and the media of the punitive
in the politics of resistance finally
visa some makers hackers and geeks in
China creativity in the Chinese
technology community I know a sense of
the range I'll just add that we just
looked at I advise the one on start an
online discourse and the one on Twitter
and trust I also advise a project on
digital literacy digital is a digital
literacy project that was being
undertaken in Brooklyn with providing
students with tablets and I also advise
to insist on podcasting and its impact
on TV writers and this was shortly after
the the writers strike which a lot of
that was around pilots issues would like
to know about the classes that you teach
yes so welcome my name is Cerf and I
direct
hi Christine Neil which operates in an
area that's called digital humanities I
also have a joint appointment with
mobile studies and languages where I
teach in German cities don't Constance
and German culture classes but our
studio is really concerned with the
changes that the visual technologies
impact on the on the teaching on
learning research
and on the creation the design in in the
humanities so we have a number of
projects but we also develop technology
we do research in this field and we also
do research in the public sphere so we
work what's called public humanities
meaning for example who worked with
museums public archives and so on so
it's really a very multifaceted approach
to rethinking what these spatial
knowledge ease mean you know for the
humanities support example we also work
with faculty here at MIT but also good
outside partners one of the projects for
example deals with the diplomatic
history between the u.s. and Iran so
this is focusing on the miscommunication
between the two countries and as you can
imagine you know this is a highly
political topic so we look at
declassified documents that have been
produced on both sides and work with
scholars in the field to basically think
where things did go wrong so we fill the
tools for that we exchange ideas and and
work with the scholars in the field to
really come up with a new way of
thinking or think these tools and
technologies and and archives actually
leave them in that space and that's also
connected to a new initiative that we
started a couple of years ago which we
call the active archives initiative and
that's really about rethinking what
digital archives mean nowadays so it's
it's a focus that we have it's primarily
on the end-user so what do end-users
really trying to
Altaf often archive so it is not so much
focusing on the content that things are
cut not focusing on the ways the archive
gets used in digitize but it's really
helping people work with archives and
this is a focus that we're trying to do
also in multiple spaces in the education
space with the research space and also
in the color space and for that we also
develop technologies so we look at for
example how can people create new layers
of meaning how they can they create
knowledge that's layered on top of the
original archival material so it has to
do with story creation it has to do with
making connections and adding the
content to those materials so one of one
of the students in the lab he works on
the employment natural language
processing and machine learning to think
about how on the one hand the archival
material can be analyzed but on the
other hand also have the future
contributions by the users for example
through annotation or through news
stories and actually be combined and
leveraged so that when you have
thousands of users that they could still
find aspects of relevant for your own
research so it's going into that
direction of rethinking combining
basically what we have done in a micro
studio in terms of projects and we've
done them for a long time so one of the
oldest research groups and besides
having graduate students you know like
rachel thompson who will be talking i
guess about what you work is yeah
as well so we also teach classes so
there's a class on official humanities
topics techniques and technologies and
that's really looking into how the
computational approach is focusing on a
critical aspect of how we need to look
at data in the humanities and how we
need to critically look at
representations visual representations
in in that class we're also developing
in a new class that's focusing a little
more on archives data archives and
interfaces and we for that we also
collaborate with with other teams in in
Germany and Switzerland so this also it
means a national idea of where if
students get involved in this research
project but these are all topic not
topic space also they have copies that
they have project-based classes so
students develop projects in a
collaborative fashion and so on so it's
also a really multifaceted program and
so they're constantly new projects
coming on board ending other
collaborations and sometimes but it's a
really interesting area of research
don't be shy that's there for you I'm
also I remember the name of Nick mouths
words three words only book in progress
one for the win
so next one here from yjq hi my name is
Waikiki I'm Leticia that's the leg
directed by my processor right I'm kind
of representing money at UT how many of
you guys are interested in education so
there are two left just and I love this
existence lat and our mission is we make
investigates the complex
technology-based classrooms of the
future and the suspense we need to help
educators drive vehicle settings so we
face a lot of our primary audience are
teachers and educators there are three
lines of work that we're doing within
home that we do online teacher education
so we want to loops one is about you
exist something people to bring
innovation to be the miracles and the
other is about you guys thinking how
teachers in these effective tools in
their own classrooms and we're kind of
case studies of those teachers are they
doing that so those are two kind of
online courses to be launched at this
year again helping teachers to bring
their practices another line of work we
go a lot of practice spaces within a lot
of radix cold air is kind of divide
between standard rooms and clinicals so
you held up teacher education
pre-service teacher is cooked with these
classes and what about those periods of
learning and teaching a lot of theories
and then without having kind of concrete
practice in between space able to
clinicals wherein the actor circuit so
what we're doing is using gameís
relations to prepare that kind of more
playful venti Cup practice spaces for
teachers
so I brought two kind of games as
exemplar game so you can proper by a
billionaire we create both not lose it
all and digital games per t-shirt so for
example in this game old man a rubric
and a mailbox I'm coming from assessment
design my friend and most people gave us
a super brain and you can say weak so we
create this game teachers can actually
design for these kind of the lost my
memory is playful assessment there's a
kind of collaboration computing systems
lab and we sure are can look where we're
creating games assessment and training
like this for teachers written a lot
about assessment and also thinking about
assessment in spaces like matrix pieces
where there's obviously love each the
investors are generating but it's not
much faster because a lot of make
bakeries in between that bacon can be of
size and how we are these any
assessments can look like that kind of
context well those I don't want to work
that very active education arcade
directed by parents left and Board of
k12 interfacing work so likes good money
be are aimed that great can learn about
stand ups and cell and things like that
and the back aids and so you guys have
had two groups we need a mic we're
getting off you
[Applause]
I mean I guess I am but that's another
place where you can denies going on in
on their website you can get a sense of
the past I'll just say way we write in
to Claudia loads Melanie my game lab but
you can also choose one of our students
we want to talk about some of her
experiences I'll do the student workbook
okay all right so to my employee low I'm
a second year student at CMS
I'm also an international student so
that experience but yeah I'm rarely here
today because how dare they all those a
lot of energies of the game lab they're
doing for dogs with teaching so we we
make things and then we play games and
we study them and we sort of
specializing the advantages but kind of
can bring to the table when it comes to
researching and teaching so for example
we have very close ties to that arcade
and I think also to ice that the
imagination creativity expression like
that said about Michael Sorel so you
know redoing we're not the only life
that has games here at CMS I so for
example two of the projects that I
participated in in our lab is we have
one long-term topic on looking at how
player 2 gets designed in games and they
started off looking purely at video
games but also has an expansion
incorporated for games so we don't like
discriminate between you know or games
versus traditional games versus video
games but all we kind of have all of
those
or purview another project that I'm on
right now is looking at representations
of colonialism for games specifically
representational aspects not in white
the game are not just sort of the
fantasy of a concept behind the board
game but like actually in sort of one of
the little pieces what do they look like
how do you move them back more that kind
of thing my own research right now so
I'm neck deep in thesis territory and my
thesis is looking at the social and
communicative work that online volunteer
moderators do so you know these are the
people who can win spend all day
removing the link that comments on
websites I'm sort of looking up what
they're doing outside of just removing
things or the move saying the comments
or make people and like am banning them
from the site way my lab me camera is
better my article her thesis is on
effect emotion and intimacy in games and
how you know we achieve those senses of
intimacy calming way and seeing if there
are mechanics in games that encourage
that sort of emotional affective
response yeah so that is the short
version I will say that the copy'
actually game logic you think you know
this means game does that all the time
actually a lot of us don't have a
background in CS or any code well it's
certainly an option but that tends to
come out in classes or even thesis work
but support for kind of coming all those
tools or finding tools generally comes
through the lab and comes through sort
of mining resources and share the
morning thank you more students before
we open up for Q&A
hi everybody my name is Ashe Kedah they
like Claudia I am a second here CMS
student which means I am also neck-deep
in thesis work I also have a tendency to
talk today it's really hard I'm working
on improving
I am the research assistant for rap
which as Heather mentioned is a my taste
writing rhetoric at professional
communication program rap fits a unique
space within the MIT community because
in addition to being a part of CMS they
oversee the communication intensive
courses for the MIT undergrads so this
means that they have a number of
instructors who go into courses specific
to engineering or into more humanities
oriented courses to talk specifically
about communication to provide
instruction in those practices and to
help students become better
communicators and this means that a
large part of their research focus is
also on how can we help students
communicate better so at present the
research project were working on is
focusing on mapping out critical
processes of thinking in different
fields those fields at present include
fields like material science and
engineering brain and cognitive science
comparative Media Studies in order to
create maps or outlines that students
can then use is they try to write papers
or work on their first writing projects
as undergrads to help people who might
be too in the weeds in their own field
as beginning learners and researchers
figure out how to take things forward
and communicate their work effectively
so in a nutshell that's what we're
working on as a part of CMS my thesis is
looking at how practices of audience
engagement have become inculcated in
news organizations so what does it mean
if someone's a social media editor or
someone's working on audience engagement
and how does that play into
sensationalism especially when society
thinks that they might be at risk in
certain situations for a given disease
feel free to ask more questions about
that later if you would like to and
let's see if there's anything else my
backgrounds in journalism so if you have
specific questions about going from
journalism to something that's not
journalism feel free to ask about that
oh yes that's a very good point
all right so I am currently the chair of
the halls at Sydney Pacific which is one
of the Graduate residence communities on
the MIT campus as chair of the halls I'm
in charge of the hall counselors in the
general well-being of somewhere between
six and seven hundred residents and said
pack and if you have any questions
specific to the well-being of students
on campus specific to how graduate
housing works for students specific to
just like the general community life on
campus at MIT I am also a very good
person to ask about those thank you CMS
student so I'm only like ankle-deep so I
have too much to say on that I'm a
research assistant in hyper studio which
that's kurt explains the digital
humanities lab at MIT I have a couple of
different projects that I work on in the
lab I make a weekly newsletter that
gathers to join humanities news across
like basically the Internet and so you
should sign up for that it's very
informative very useful I also am a
teaching assistant for history with
manatees class so I you know go to the
class and like help we get discussion
and kind of present on things I'm a
background in art museums and art I work
hard art museums and I worked at the
Peabody Essex Museum up in Salem in
there like media departments so I'm also
specifically Kurt has an AA project art
bot and I could talk to you a little bit
more about that but it's on the back
burner right now but you know we're
hoping to get it back up I work on
another project which is annotation
studio which falls under the active
archives initiative it's a tool that is
and all my tools for collaborative
annotation
in pedagogical situations within the
classroom so classes in all within the
same checks all annotated and everyone
can kind of see and share each other's
annotations as kind of a springboard for
talking in class discussion or
understanding types and at the same time
we're hoping to develop a new tool which
is ideas space which is to create hope
you outline essays from the annotations
that you would make an annotation studio
so you can kind of see where we're going
from reading and writing and better
understanding close reading to better
understanding the writing process so
we're currently working on I'm helping
work on an image proposal through that
right now otherwise I can't tell you
much about theses I'm interested in
across media that's about as far ladler
variable tip is the career in SPF we
have students from all five schools
within MIT from architecture engineering
and we work our focuses on applying
human centered design and theories
design through placement of partners so
we work with oliver project search for
30 and we've worked with costing the
series from food and nutrition to
connect advices and lighting so
currently we have 170 is working the
best in our connected lighting projects
for color design in seeing how we can
sit
lighting devices connectivity I attended
all of those with for the future city
another projects that we've done in the
past which we had multiple team of
students and was our caring cities
project which was a very economically
focused projects where we help students
not just put the demons but also
different apartments Hui and maybe
search on services and products which is
provided with David sharing city we get
where we're currently about about 15 to
20 people from credits to do some
undergraduate research so this could be
[Music]
okay then we are open for Q&A there is
no sort of standardized system in place
for you know here's here's how you're
gonna publish at least by the end of
your first or second year that we don't
work that way I was thinking in
particular of the fact that some
professors collaborate with students
like Lisa Parke says collaborate with
her graduate students actually co-edited
a book with one for students at UCSD at
Santa Barbara before she came here
other students work together to get
conference presentations Kaelin is
[Music]
and both of us so our the players shoot
research we did sort of part of that we
brought up on some paper and both killer
than my kids my lammie closable Scott
co-ownership credit what stage of the
research help get those to a stage where
they're ready to and it's just helpful
to remember that your professor your
faculties are your fact the fact that
you're here is it's kind of mentors to
you so if you write a paper for them
they're like aha this is publishable
let's revise it you know they work with
you or if you come to them and say I
actually would like to publish because I
want to go to graduate school in a year
or two you know you can work
collaboratively to up your credentials
enough yeah and we've done that in
hundreds of you as well so the involving
the RAS
so museums on the web and that including
also writing proposals for conferences
for example thing that also for
companies proceedings and so on so it's
always a collaborative yeah yeah some of
us um you know most these labs have some
kind of deliverable which might need a
white paper that they need you to
collaborate on in the case of open not
glad students will quite often go to
Sundance and they film as well and they
will vlog about that so there might be
kinds of informal writing such as
blogging
the world what do look foremost in
statement of objectives previous
achievement research experience personal
story related to this era or anything
that's a good question um personal
stories are nice because they give you
something what the person is like but
you know I will say a long story about
like here's how I came to love Dungeons
& Dragons we've seen those go the long
personal story about why you love games
it's a nice opener but don't go off in
the two months in that direction we'd
really want to hear about what your
interests are your objectives and you
know the kinds of experiences that you
bring to the program that would be
unique benefit us and you we do since
sometimes take before I out of college
that happens but usually yeh but quite
often if someone who's been out for a
year or two or maybe a little bit more
because we like that level of life
experience at work experience and I
would say also sometimes people might
have undergraduate training and
something that is not that has
applicability to what we do but they
don't have a supersized background but
then they go out and they make
documentary film for two years or they
work or they pursue a not-for-profit and
it increases their credentials in that
area and it sort of sort of makes them
into it in a way that they might not
have been writing either so any of the
specific kind of intellectual and help
convey who you are my interests are
would be helpful your statement of
objectives also of course you submit a
writing sample which should be on early
work of some substance and that conveys
your interests but it also conveys you
know your basic writing skills and your
approach to writing
sell-on so you know occasionally someone
will will get in his writing samples
really about media at all but they they
clearly have the chops for the program
they have the background they have the
grades that you know this is not but
what they had available to reading
snuffle might have been an undergrad
American art history paper that wasn't
directly relevant to us but it showed
creativity and research so there is and
I've been you know interested about your
program and I was curious if in terms of
writing and what I'm looking for is
going to get like some kind of I feel
like we all are struggling with this
information saturation and how do we and
I was really fascinated by some of the
projects that came program so it's
really curious about is this a place for
somebody who's trying would be writing
for awhile but wants to do something out
of the box what kind of writing with you
done all kinds I got in speeches for my
director producing
but I also know that I think rewrite it
for new audiences it's not the same and
I feel like even from when I first
started my career to know if you so much
as changed right inviting attention
spans thank you so much so I think the
struggle is because you know my team so
that's why it's hard but now the water
podcast is like I want to be within
something the last not adding to the
noise so I think yeah that just points
to really distinct sort of
non-traditional background for an
applicant we definitely do the dive
again from people who are from a career
pretty often and so I would encourage
you to apply I'll ask it sometimes the
people have been away from school for a
long time they don't have a range net
one hand that makes sense of that and
sometimes people will write something
from scratch specifically for the
application the nature of contemporary
podcasting you know something that is up
their alley but they write a research
paper on
yeah that's what I did I went I did my
undergraduate degree in America also and
so my you know today was the same for
those yeah if you have or will have by
the time you articulate in degree from
an english-speaking University before
the application it must be verifiable my
transcript so when you upload your
transcript it needs to be in English and
I need to be able to buy a very quick
search verifying that your course was
taught English there's very rare
occasional thing where someone switch
out for various reasons and to expand on
that
do you state in your statement of
objectives which lab you would like to
work on or do you choose when you come
in um there is a space and and we might
we might tweak this a little bit how
people indicate their interest in the
application because what we find is if
we say you know would you be able to you
know what loudly be abusive people tend
to list like eight or nine laughs you
know they looks all loud because they're
all very interesting and and so although
it's fine to express an interest we're
typically looking at your qualifications
to see where you might be the best fit
and then by the time we get to the
semi-finalists stage we have this we
have maybe too many details but we have
we have typically five groups of two two
professors who are or research manager
we were examining everything and making
the cut from 180 to 60 by our final mean
we're like 35 or so my timer at the
semi-finalists stage we like to show all
the applications to the eyes and the lab
managers so that they can red flag
anyone that they're like yeah that
person looks like a good match for me
and so it's a mix of you know your
stated preference but also what we see
looking at your qualifications so it's
not the most pressing part of your
application to click off I would like to
be inside blacks I would say about 30%
of the time stick we have the class of
10 about three of them we will go up for
a ph.d program and pretty often right
out of the master's program especially
if there's someone you know two three or
four years off between undergrad and
come here or even more time they want to
just keep it limited going and go on the
big stage occasionally yes we will have
students go into which show which
program is Eric statement SPS SPS
science and technology studies I don't
think we've had students go back to the
lab we have okay oh right yeah of course
so the Media Lab can you think of other
yes that's Jeff Lily urban study design
in urban studies department of urban
citizen planted thank you so we have a
range of people who do stay at MIT but
that's I wouldn't say every year
somebody stays at MIT among the say
three or so who either graduate staying
people apply for a lot of programs in
California in particular a couple of New
York Harvard yeah that happens
so it is it is a mix I would say maybe
half those pretty sure yeah so I'm sorta
back on the rating thing what sympathies
would there be coming from and not so I
like I went to go for animation anomaly
comic so I don't really have a whole lot
of academic experience the same way that
like anybody that much of the normal
liberal arts school it's hard to
immediate really depending on you know
what your whole portfolio experiences it
looks like you know if someone conveys
that they are articulate and can use
language absolutely you know in their
statement of objectives they have a self
right example then the fact that they
have not come from a conventional it's
fine in fact it's a plus because you
bring the sort of life skills if someone
else and so worried about if you're
looking any principles picking the
portfolio section and how
fatherhood kind of value-added you know
it's it's it's it's if you put things in
your portfolio we will look at them but
it will often be the last movie when we
have the basics first GRE scores the
writing and the transcript and this and
that but then the portfolio is nice
because if you say the earring game
designer and you write a paper about
this amazing game you created get up
we're going to take a look you know some
people put up art city where comics it
would make sense to comics work and so
it's a very helpful supplement to and
especially for someone from the less
dimensional background it's more than
potentially bat side if you don't have
something for your portfolio
okay so when I apply here my
undergraduate back back ones in filming
media and devorah studies but are sort
of assault on games studies and so when
I came here you know statement of
deckers of southern like emphasize to my
work in creating studies and when I got
here there's no weekend I was like I'm
not writing about that I'm waiting I'm
going to write about because I also the
moderator on fine for a long time that
sort of compromised because the marks
that I'm looking at are working in
it are working in these work related
areas so it's like nicely matching
bridge those two and I will say I
settled on that topic after we can kind
of have stuck with it memory till now so
this is I think a lot of us had like an
idea and now we did that I would say
that mine came in a similar vein it was
definitely more of a funnel process I
started kind of broad with the fact that
I had these seemingly disparate
interests in like social media and how
news organizations work and also Public
Health and then I think the question
that I asked myself over the first year
of the program was how can I mix these
together into something that I would
find interesting and exciting that I
would want to work on for another year
right and over the course of asking
myself that question repeatedly
particularly given that in our theories
and methods courses our professors make
us poke and prod at what we're
interested in over the course of the
assignments it narrowed down it to
something that was like an actual
question that I was excited about
looking at and answering and thinking
about in more detail you want to give it
a shot so I come back round and I wrote
my undergraduate thesis on digital
literary magazine so I'm like shifting
we want any now and like working at
incarceration and so that's kind of why
I'm looking
incarceration but I came in originally
and I was interested in education
specifically in situations of
incarceration however there are very
strict standards about doing research
about identity do your research infuse
and so prisons and youth it's like the
worst combination that you could have so
now I'm kind of in lieu of that I'm
circling by looking at like the politics
of representation and crime media rather
now Zoomer is one of our grad students
who just came in Vicki which do you want
to join us up here and would you mind I
get you will interview yourself and
maybe talking a bit about your pieces
and your lab but I'm Vicki I'm a second
year in CMS I'm working with Lisa parts
in global media technologies and
cultures lab my own thesis is on how the
fine dining industry is wrestling with
the ever-changing nature of digital
media and communication so for example
like how does food porn and Instagram
influence or is it considered by like
three Michelin star chefs and sort of
like taking like a historical look at
how fine dining is wrestled with
technology change and then also looking
at today with what they're doing with it
and within my lab it's a little
different than my own research interest
but I actually really enjoy that because
I think it's kind of nice to have some
separation and it's also showing me a
lot of areas within communication and
media technology that I never would have
explored myself so I'm really
appreciating getting a totally new
perspective and Professor parks is
fantastic so I'm really happy with that
yeah our GRE scores lead as more equally
or less important than the statement of
objectives / writing slam a little
splash GPA / work experience I think it
varies from application to application
how relevant GRE scores if we see a
pattern of someone who's not a very
strong writer and they're stating the
purpose of their writing sample and they
had no injuries scores throughout if
someone who has exceptionally strong
writing skills and yet they had a low
verbals you know or someone might have
much higher verbal skills than self
expression in a musical scale so it
varies from application to application
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but I mean also just yeah and like to
add on that I think coming from MIT it
really helps you get your door and put
your foot in I just woke up like an hour
ago
and for example like just emailing
people that are visiting Harvard or
visiting MIT and like I'm also a grad
student at MIT they'll usually respond
to you it's been pretty nice um but also
like I think you have to take the
initiative saying like okay I want to
meet these kind of people and once you
take that initiative there are people
that will help you like I always go to
Shannon they like to tune in do you know
anybody who does this and and she's like
oh I know all these people let me lick
them up or and you're with your
professors but nobody's nobody's gonna
be like okay you need to learn how to
network and I want you to meet XYZ you
sort of have to say like I would like to
meet these people in this field do you
know anyone and then it's easy from
there I said about that I think often
times when I think I'm networking it's
more like who would I be very interested
in talking to our asking questions and
then if I have that level of interest
then I'm like okay let me just send them
an email or find someone who knows their
email and then just do it that way or
maybe they're giving a talk because
there's lots of people getting taught
that MIT and Harvard and I'll just go
say hi I think I'm also the sort of
person who if I see an event that says
networking in big letters I will not go
in that sense I'm actually kind of
appreciative of CMS does not say go to
this networking if that ferny that would
be just like a very instant antov
in substantive waste of time like I just
I do not enjoy those so there they exist
you can go to them if you want to but I
personally have avoided all of those
with very success and I think I've still
been pretty good
everything just because there are lots
of really cool people here doing very
cool things and if you get in touch and
you're like hi I want to talk to you
because your stuff is cool then they're
usually like yeah I'd love to do that
people enjoy talking about themselves
yes and also like cmus is really a
department where if you want to do
something and you take the initiative
like you could pretty much do what you
want so like if I decided ok we don't
have a networking event for alums or
people in this but if I was like hey
Heather Mattoon and like can we have
like a little coffee thing for CMS alums
in Boston and I'm I'm more than a
hundred percent sure and Andrew - that
they would help me figure out how to
make that happen yeah so it's it's kind
of like what's the program you want it
to be and how can you help me get that
but not like Business School where you
have like once a week these events where
you have to go and talk the students
speak to that I would say that you have
elective opportunities the national open
electives and that is how you might work
[Music]
so yeah I think Lulu is make sure your
ideas if you also have any one other
reader and they don't have so yeah so we
asked people currently we generally they
get early ago an advance copy
so we're going to read it first
yes but also last year there was a
project I was really interested in in
the media life piece I did sort of the
food technology and social media and
they were using food and big data and
looking at communities there and I just
emailed them and said hey I'm like
writing my thesis on it kindly figure
out what's going on and like once a week
I touched base with them and got to kind
of help a little bit on the project but
it is you have to be watch out your time
don't have a lot of it but I it was like
part of my thesis work and I people are
pretty friendly in that respect if
there's something you're interested in
to something evil or show up and their
lab they
[Music]
and so that's that's you know where they
put
so it's not just but that is to say
there are a few people that have been ah
raised in the open doc lab that their
thesis work is more hands-on and I think
that's really complemented their work as
aa raised very well so I know a lot of
people that have been in da club are
raised has more technical project-based
pieces yeah and I would recommend you
emailing boxer L runs that lab he's my
lead research lead but my experiences
[Music]
and he has hidden press appointment and
Lisi say all aboard yeah so he works
with computer science graduate PhD
students whose work without answers
he will not be looking at any applicants
this year but when we review applicants
we are always thinking who could this
person potentially work with and so for
example even if some [ __ ] leaves we
might say hey look at these three
students you know just having one of
them in your lab next year or you know
look at the Hulbert who looks
appropriate for you so because he is
running a lab he suddenly would check in
with but you don't have to worry about
working in an area and your person is
not completely in the program how much
of the work load is essays versus
hands-on work and for the thesis is it
possible to do a journalism project or
startup idea for instance most of the
work by each I mean more than 50% on
patient projects but the majority work
and I would have to see specifically
with the party list but a short answer
is that no one is going to rated theses
that their HP or startup company in
death
so that's that and you might write it
uses that helps you start up that Bible
3 when you get out of here you know that
lays down the groundwork or what you
want to do or lays out the key funders
foundation so it's not that that work is
unrelated piece itself would not I guess
I'm interested in hearing from the
students what you think sets in my
teeths program apart from other media
studies programs or maybe why you
decided yeah let's say for me and I
can't really say it all right so as I
said before my New York for a year
before I came here and when I started
thinking about grad school I was like
this is really great but there are so
many gaps in my knowledge right there
are other things related to media but
there aren't necessarily journalism that
I'm interested in and possibly want to
work with for Sunday so when I was
looking for grad program I did apply to
a couple of journalism ones but I also
applied to CMS because it's more broad
the scope is different you can look at
more issues more things you get to
explore more because CMS is very very
interdisciplinary in a way that many
other programs are not and for me that
was the big draw because you get to work
with media in so many different
capacities that might not be possible
yeah and I also kind of agree with that
I was
I majored in American Studies and Media
Arts and Sciences which is like computer
science and design so -
interdisciplinary majors and I still
wanted to continue that comparative look
at
technology and stuff for me when I was
looking at programs I was looking at
what communication programs also have
cross pollination with human-computer
interaction or at least around resources
like that and a lot of the communication
programs I was looking at we're like
political focused or health focused or
seemed very focused and so I really
wanted to go somewhere where I could
have like this core of Media Studies and
communication but I could talk to people
in computer science really readily or I
could talk to somebody who studied
virtual reality in this stuff where I
could go and talk to a chef and then at
those sort of ventures off would be
normalized in a way and I went to have
to fight against being able to have like
an anthropology person look at my thesis
and what would the perspective they
would get is we were communications
department and so in CMS I feel like
every single person is doing something
totally different from each other and I
love that piece it really allows you to
to be empowered to like have the
perspective you want to take while still
having a lot of other perspectives of
people who have also done kind of
different things and how do you make
sure it's legitimate while also knew
when disciplinary
[Music]
[Music]
but I another nice thing about straight
outside of your building way to use
methods from another and I also want to
add one thing what I liked about CMS is
that there were people who went into
academia there were people that went
into industry and it was totally
accepted where a lot of the academic
programs I was looking at Slyke more
training future scholars and if you end
up going into industry it's like you
sort of have betrayed your professors or
are you have like let yourself down by
not getting an academic job and in CMS
it's it's both are like viewed
completely the same way in terms of how
people respect them and how people will
help you get to where you want to be and
so that was really important for me
because I didn't know if I was gonna go
I felt like I was gonna go into PhD it
still might but I need time off I I was
like I'm not sure and I don't want to go
down a path where I'm gonna finish and
the only option is to go into academia I
want to be somewhere where I can finish
my masters and say okay I'm gonna
continue into a PhD or no I'm going to
go work in industry and I have the tools
I need to do that and I feel like CMS is
definitely Mabley need to have those
those dual options
exposing the application anywhere else
you apply puffle first to see the Rachel
your reduced that way and in that
program you know by a number of people
you apply to both PhD programs and
master to their lives and then they see
where they get in and then they sort of
wait it balance everything you figure
out what are my priorities and you know
it's done the tipping point is while I
got into the specifics they put or the
best program I got into this program do
I want tinia you know being
professionally my only option when I'm
done so yeah I had to make that decision
I was choosing between a PhD and Karen
from here you can always go on to get a
PhD and once you're in the peach you
can't go back and do see and of course
there's a difficulty is that the job
market is particularly proper yeah so
it's very very I would say there may be
an environment for the achieve and so
you have a master's degree do a lot of
different options one of the big issues
that other ones be history or whatever
you just have more options just as a
cross-check it seems to be getting the
most of that but what bar the
comparables
I'm here and I wished I could see the
value of the program but I just wonder
just as an exercise what would you
compare this program to learn how are
you different from it by nano and are
there programs where that are less
writing based there are technically
oriented programs it's very game
I salute the main six RS NYU I can see
it's a and you an NYU ITP is like a lot
more hands-on if you're more of like a
maker I like to just yeah are they more
hands-on and you will not be doing
writing yeah there are limited areas
like it's got some iterative claims like
it's a documentary training right now
there is a program in social justice and
documentary at the New School for Social
Research in New York City right which
were training for sacramentary so
there's some very specific there is I
can start in um so this past summer I
interned at Google doing user research a
user experience research in the research
and machine intelligence group there
I did have past professional experience
in UX research as well but before I got
that I was planning on going to Spain
and doing fieldwork and I was gonna get
funding through MIT Spain to do that so
there are options you need to I'm not
I'm not familiar with CMS options for
summer independent thesis work but there
are a bunch of random places at MIT that
money for students to do things in the
summer I knew did you get pkg okay so
then there's the pkg what does this yeah
how what is the same fortune that I'm
sorry yeah we had I think two students
this past summer who used that fun for
their summer work so I think Azaria
whose inner year went to Argentina
serious and working with an alum I think
or maybe not I don't know it was my
project I'm sorry but then also Marielle
who's also a second year got funding
from there to run a student media
workshop and he's Faust in the summer so
the shorter interest here up or whatever
you need to sometimes it is something
you realize no and that's productive
direction but people need to do
fieldwork graphically sure you do that
in the summer there are a lot of pots of
money and lanky that you can apply for
not specifically your CMS though for
summer important as far as I know what
does the Kelly Douglas fund is is for
research travel and can be used oh yes
it's for research travel but it's a
relatively small amount um but that is
generally used most often for conference
travel during school year there are some
students do summer
Microsoft Research chips so there's a
you might be thinking research of Mexico
City and you should be looking for
Mexico City you should be looking for
international funds that thinking about
your specific yeah yeah and I do have a
tip of advice I wish I was applying for
grants for my research right when I got
here rather than waiting until my second
year see as it takes foundations like a
year to give you money
yeah so I like I found all these pots of
money but if they take months and months
to process and so now that I'm beginning
in my second year they're like we can
give you the money in April and like
that hopefully we will be done so if you
know that you're gonna need money for
some general topic maybe don't know
specifically where when you get here
start looking what you get going but we
don't wanted to show up to do research
in their life absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
it is unusual
[Music]
[Music]
oh you're you're absolutely right that
Turk tank is the place that would
potentially be doing work that would be
a great interest to you
but that doesn't mean that you'd be
entertaining if you came here depending
on who else got in and where people fit
whether or not to obtain heavenly
finding that year what their ranks they
have in the works and so on so you do
not want to come here specifically just
because I gotta go to my teeth I work in
Kaitlyn and you just paid your spot that
is not a good criterion I think we're
clear that said if you want to work you
know let's say that you wanted to be an
open top level you got a package to do
is you are a something but opened a lot
it has meetings almost every week with
guest speakers and free sandwiches and
you can participate another lapse it's
in the media lab we've not been able to
play people in the Civic Media Lab for
two years something like that
but people attend those lab meetings if
they choose to you know soon how much
time you have in the day but you know
people who you know can can find ways to
connect
not necessarily work before and if
you're open to okay to connecting in
that way that's not so research
assignment or your it works it to earn
your way mom that's fine but I would not
recommend anyone choosing this just
because I gotta be decide that it's one
lab work with just one professor and
that you wanted to apply you can write
as many programs as you want
oh I'm sorry being one push over here
than you do not assign you pick an
advisor I just picked it up but maybe
you guys could speak to it'll anymore
I think a union so the way I went about
it is when I started thinking of a
thesis topic I kind of looked at the
list of course EMS faculty because your
primary thesis advisor has to be from
Siena and I was just like hi I'm
thinking about these things can I come
meet with you for a bit to talk about
this and I think I did that with three
different professors towards the end of
first semester beginning of the second
semester and sort of after my thought
process had kind of taken more shape I
went to two of them at the end of the
spring semester and I talked to them
again and sort of based on that
discussion and asking them like how do
you work as an advisor what is your
process for working with grad students I
went back to one per cluster and I was
like okay would you be my thesis advisor
so for me it was a process of thinking
about what the professor is interested
in what I'm interested and also how the
professor functions as an advisor like
do they want to meet you once a week do
they require that you make
with deadlines like how does that
professor work what do they bring to the
table and then after talking to them and
just generally seen how it felt picking
one I think it's good to just point to
the back you need the right topic match
somebody right yes but you also need the
right sort of approach to work they work
however mismatch and some people really
need a lot of hand-holding and very very
effective when other people prefer to be
more self-directed and you need to find
the advisor that I'm just gonna say yeah
for me like the biggest consideration is
who had the theoretical or topic
background then the working style was a
huge thing for me because I'm somebody
that I like being self-directed I don't
like having tight deadlines I just
getting by and do nothing I'm much
better at like just have it done by
February and I'll do it no word um
hopefully we don't know yet but so it
was really important for me to find the
professor who would be okay with
trusting me with that space but I also
knew that when I sent them an email with
work I wanted them to look at they would
be able to give me relevant feedback
because as I said like I I'm leaving I
want my pieces to be able to be read by
people in the food industry not just be
like a very academic test so I didn't
want to be working with the professor
whose only zoned into academic writing
and interfere I wanted somebody who
would help me be able to write my thesis
in a way there would be more readable by
general population so I think that also
is like tone in how are the people that
know your audience as well
you know how they eat berries some of
them are very small whatever we heard
from who said you know what we have in
that students we also we have all over
these and the size you know I I don't
know if
generally I think the top of the bell
curve and on the other side would be the
the design lab where there's many under
gravity which many value my students my
research staff and then letter
presidents and even some of them have
infiltrated the Australian assistance
they were administrative assistants so
it really varies
yeah what's helpful there is if you are
you know that you have funding and this
has to be I same work from
students who may have support from they
are government that you can buy X amount
of money for International Research
people come in with that kind of support
we don't want to drain your cities the
most important thing for you to do in
the online application there is a box
that asks if you are interested in
financial aid
please check yes because that is what
makes you eligible for the research
assistantship which provides full
tuition plus of the news that I'm really
good health insurance and for
international students you do not have
until you are admitted that is a
separate process that has to do with the
f1 visa application and that doesn't
just in the application yes I'm
interested it's fairly civil and you
will be considered for research and
somewhere that the funding is kind of
tied to one of the labs and those are
another question do you all have a
conference for our CV or a resume or
both or doesn't matter whether you're
formatted as a CV or more conventional
resume I'll just say that sometimes
resumes people think I can only have one
page running back and obviously we want
all your experience
is just we want to see your experiences
education background someone and we
properly formatted if it's our run here
all right well let me remind you that we
have this colloquium in the room is
56:56
the building type in there 1 1 4 that is
from 5:00 to 6:30 that's with our four
alumni and on a panel so I have it many
[Applause]